totally overmedicated it was so fast the
weight gain you think of putting a stone
on a month
can you imagine what that's like it's
heartbreaking heartbreaking for honey to
see heartbreaking for us to see and you
just worry about the medically
implications of it as well
Holly's drastic weight gain was a side
effect of the medication it was part of
her mental health treatment but staff at
the unit where Holly was held didn't
know how to deal with her autism they
were quite rough they would grab you
you'd have in my first unit you'd have
you'd be on the floor Eve on the
mattress or on the floor the hard floor
and you have one person on one leg on
personally I've led one person in your
path soon on the other someone I'm head
Holly's condition means she doesn't like
to be touched now pinning her to the
ground would only increase her anxiety
on one occasion she was restrained for
nearly four hours it doesn't really help
you like learn to cope because you're
just having someone physically stop you
for the time being like you and there's
not like someone telling you you're
therapies like coping strategies her
mother Emma told me she felt helpless
watching her daughter's condition
deteriorate
heartbroken is the word really nobody
wants someone to lay hands on your kid
and so you know you think if I was there
I'd stop them because she she was only
being herself
holy and Emma say the staff at a unit
were poorly trained and simply couldn't
cope with people with autism it's a
recurring criticism of what's been
described as a broken system yesterday
on Sky News we reported on the case of
Bethany an autistic teenager locked up
for 24 hours a day in solitary
confinement she's just one of more than
2,000 people with a learning disability
or autism currently being held in a
secure unit in England of these 235 are
on
at the age of 18 tomorrow the Joint
Committee on Human Rights will publish a
damning report and the detention of
young people with learning disabilities
and/or autism their evidence will point
to a failure to protect our most
vulnerable young people Polly says she
feels much better now but she wants
people to know what really happens
inside these units I'm feeling more free
to like be part of this and to have
someone hear what I had to say we would
move heaven and earth to stop it
happening again we would never ask that
sort of help ever again we'd weird
work ourselves into the ground in folly
was really low again to that point where
we needed needed help I don't think we'd
ask our shishio she Sky News